il je les trouvais avenant gentil et
j'ai une anecdote où on avait parlé de
notre de notre passion commune pour les
petits chiens et ce tout en tout temps
avec mes chiens et du coup bah c'était
un moment hyper agréable et jean-paul un
souvenir exceptionnel soit c'est vrai
qu'on a un petit peu triste et que
c'était un méchant paul il avait
toujours le sourire qui sans moi dès
qu'il voyait ma gueule il fait rigoler
gradina alors non pas si j'ai un regret
je vous lis et que cet été
je faisais du bois
multiples petites histoires rigolotes
toc toc badaboum
tiens
et si
mal c'est vrai qu'on a vus ensemble à
cannes il ya deux ans on a déjà dit je
crois ensemble bah ouais c'est c'est
d'abord on pleure à un pan de vie pour
tous c'est là que ça correspond à des
tas de souvenirs un mois j'ai eu la
chance de le rencontrer très souvent
très souvent j'ai fait j'avais fait les
essais pour l'as des as voilà vous
deviez tout petit mais les petits comme
j'étais très très blond fait pour le
rôle c'était moyen moyen mais c'est la
chance de passer les essais puis je le
voyais très souvent ces faits les
sorties de chine avec lui parce que mon
père était très pote avec lui j'ai fait
la sortie du professionnel il y avait
cette grande allée y avait paul il y
avait à l'époque stephen monaco il y
avait hier secondes pour moi petite
enfance était était fou les morfalous
jeu était encore là et puis on se
croisait de temps en temps il serait
qu'à chaque fois il était d'une
gentillesse et d'une simplicité et sa
vie disait une chose très juste il est
des gens qui ont la grosse tête ils
naissent avec la grosse tête si vous
avez la grosse tête quand vous êtes chef
de rayon va vous aurez la grosse tête
mais ce mec-là qui était sans rire je
pense que c'est aller c'est l'une des
plus grandes stars du cinéma français il
ya une carrière qui traverse à la fois
les films d'auteur la nouvelle vague
mais des films commerciaux il a tout
inventé il était le premier de
producteurs c'était un acteur hors norme
refusé au conservatoire ca qu ils
étaient où on ne voulait pas donc c'est
un génie de la comédie et il aimait
jouer il adorait jouer c'est ce qu'ils
préféraient faire le plus grand dans la
vie et c'est vrai que si on est si
triste de ce soir il n'aurait pas aimé
qu'on soit riche tous
c'est parce qu'il correspond à chacun à
un moment de notre vie et moi c'est moi
enfance et mon adolescence voilà et
c'est bouleversant parce que quand
candelon sera parti la boucle sera
bouclée malheureusement